the dads amongst you you know I can't
say very much so what I will see is
virtually the statement I issued last
Sunday I am certain that I have done
nothing wrong and tend to be back in
Parliament in the early part of the week
I'll make myself available for questions
then obviously within the constraints
that I'm referring to right now for now
I intend to go home and catch up with
some family I know I'm a public figure I
accept what comes with that but I'm also
a human being that's entitled to a bit
of privacy and my neighbors are also
entitled to it because it play as well
so thank you very much have you
considered stepping back from the SMP
I've done nothing wrong and that is the
only thing and I'm going to set up to be
have there been conditions placed on
your arrest
no and I'm not going to get into
anything other than that would Nicola
sturgeon have suspended Nicholas
sturgeon I've done nothing wrong it's
for others to come in as they see fit
but that's Michael's
thank you
foreign
public appearance from the former first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon following
that period of detention in police
custody for more than seven hours one
week ago this was